YUFENG GUO: Are you
looking to run machine
learning on Docker containers
in the cloud, future proofing
your workflow and
allowing you to use
any library of your choice?
If so, then you've come
to the right place.
Because today, we're going
to run custom containers
on Google Cloud AI Platform.
[TONES]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode, we're going
to use AI Platform's custom
containers to see how to run
custom training jobs on Google
Cloud using Docker containers.
This approach gives us a
number of key benefits.
First is faster start up time.
If you use a custom container
with all of your dependencies
preinstalled, you
can save the time
that your training
application would otherwise
take to install those
dependencies when starting up.
So that gives you faster
training and fewer network
and compute resources used.
Second, you can use any machine
learning framework you want.
Just install your
chosen framework
in your custom
container and then just
use it to run those
jobs on AI Platform.
This not only means you can
use every tool under the sun,
but it also future
proofs your workflow,
allowing you to easily
switch libraries or add
new ones for experimentation.
Third-- and this is a little bit
related to the previous point--
you can use the latest
build of a library.
Or if you want an
older version--
if that's what
you're relying on--
that's great too.
No one will force you to
update if you're not ready.
It's your container.
It's also worth pointing
out that since you're
building your own
container image,
that if you want a
certain functionality,
you're going to
have to install it.
So if you want something like
hyperparameter tuning or GPU
support, you'll need
to make sure to include
the necessary libraries to
make those features work.
OK.
Let's look at how you
can use custom containers
to train a model.
We're going to try to use
PyTorch to train on MNIST,
just to show off the
tooling and process.
First things first, we've
got to create the container.
Now I know that some parts
of the data science community
are a bit against learning yet
another tool to do their work.
But I'm hoping that you're
here to learn new things.
Plus, it definitely seems like
containers are here to stay.
So it will be really
useful to learn this tool.
Our Dockerfile installs
PyTorch, Cloud ML Hypertune,
and downloads gsutil for
exporting cloud storage.
And then it
configures some PATs.
Finally, it copies
in the training code
and then sets it up
to run right when
the container starts executing.
Be sure to test your
Dockerfile locally
before you use it by building
that image and running it.
Then, you can push it off to
Google Container Registry,
or GCR.
That's where AI Platform
will look for your image
during the training job.
Once you have your image
uploaded to GCR, creating a job
is quite similar to normal
usage of AI Platform Training.
There's just one extra
command line argument when
you submit that training job.
You want to make sure you
include --master-image-uri
and pass in that GCR URI.
At this point you
might be wondering,
why go through all the
trouble of building a Docker
image if we could just
run the training locally?
There is a couple of
scenarios, I can imagine,
where this would be
particularly useful.
Perhaps your data is larger
than your machine's storage
or the data set is
secured behind permissions
so you can't run
the full training
job on a local machine.
Or maybe the compute resources
of your local machine
just aren't adequate
because you need
something like multiple GPUs.
Third reason might
be that you want
to do distributed training
across many machines,
or you want to run many jobs
in parallel to each other,
or you just really like
working with containers.
Hey, that's always
a possibility.
For those who need containers,
AI Platform Training
with custom containers provides
a great new set of features
and functionality to explore.
I can't wait to hear about how
you containerize your model.
Thanks for watching this episode
of Cloud "AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out AI Platform
Custom Containers for all
your custom training needs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]